Sometimes we only want our code to
execute if it satisfies certain
conditions.
For instance, I might want to go for
a run but only if it's sunny outside.
If it's raining I'd like
to go to the gym instead.
This can be done in Ruby
with someone's control flow.
We can use special keywords like if,
unless, and
else to guide the logic in our programs.
Let's break apart our previous example.
It's sunny outside,
can be singled out as an expression.
This expression is either true or false.
If and
only if that expression is true we want
to move forward with certain actions.
Let's take a deeper dive into how
we can evaluate expressions and
use control flow to make
our programs more dynamic.